hey what's up guys i'm kphd here and i
am shooting my first video vlog style
with a front-facing camera thumbs up for
that if you've never seen that before
but anyway i'm taking the time to record
this video to let you guys know a few
things as you can probably see by the
title up there it's been a pretty crazy
week for me and i'm going to give you a
little bit of information about that as
well as some info on the future which is
behind me so as you guys may or may not
have already heard of hurricane sandy
which swept the whole east coast of the
united states which is right outside my
window here uh it killed the power so
there hasn't been electricity or heat in
this building in i think it's day 11 now
so 11 days
so this whole deal here is not
operational without electricity of
course so you can see the empty shell
that is the mac pro down there i'm bad
with this front facing camera stuff but
uh yeah so i haven't been able to make
any videos but i have a lot of videos
lined up both in my head
and on this index card over here i've
been writing down video ideas i can't
reveal those though that would be a bad
idea
uh so yeah i have a whole lot of videos
stacked up but
uh so over the past couple of days it's
been weird the first day the hurricane
hit monday night lost power but that
wasn't too bad i was able to sleep
through that but then we haven't had
anything since then the streets flooded
now the water's gone but now people are
getting their basements redone
electricity is being turned back on
hopefully i will have power in this
building soon that being said i have a
lot of videos and stuff planned for the
second these lights turn back on
and uh two of them are really really
cool so i'm gonna go ahead and give you
a hint over here some stuff that has not
yet been covered yet but you guys
already know there's a lot of great
stuff going on if you want updates on
this stuff because a lot of you guys
already knew this
twitter.commkbhd that's where it's at
and if you're feeling daring google plus
which is also down below the like button
on this video and you can check out uh
some interesting stuff i've been sharing
there too
also to note the iphone 5 and galaxy
note 2 giveaway that winner will be
selected very soon also updates will be
on twitter for that so you're going to
make sure you stay tuned on twitter
that's going to be picked very soon
so stay tuned that's very important and
uh last but not least uh i've been
charging my gadgets shout out to my
neighbor slash teammates who have been
helping me out because they have power
across the street so i'm going over
there
uh a lot and charging my stuff and uh
hopefully i'll be able to use his
internet to upload this video either way
i want to thank you guys for watching
thank you guys for being supportive i've
gotten a lot of comments you know asking
if i'm okay yes i'm okay yes i am doing
fine without electricity rocking in the
corner slowly no i'm just kidding i'm
being fine but um that's basically it i
just wanted to let you guys know i have
a lot of fun videos planned so thumbs up
if you're ready for that awesome uh
swarm of content as soon as these lights
turn back on
and i'll catch you guys later
peace stop button
stop button